I've shifted to a place of trying to
live every day as if it's my first life
is precious we get that right what do
you do when the power goes
out you improvise sulea jwad is an
artist she's an Emmy award-winning New
York Times columnist and author of The
New York Times best-selling Memoir
between two kingdoms at age 22 sulea was
diagnosed with leukemia beat the ODS and
went into remission a decade later
however her cancer returned that
happened to coincide with her boyfriend
now husband John batist being celebrated
with 11 Grammy nominations the most of
any artist the world was moving on and I
was profoundly stuck if you see one
documentary this year see American
Symphony produced by the Obamas that
Chronicles Su Lake's cancer recurrence I
was stepping into the role role of a war
correspondent and Reporting from the
front lines of my hospital
bed I absolutely adore sulea she is a
stunning and beautiful example of
strength and her openness and
vulnerability in this conversation is
beyond moving hope feels like a
dangerous and risky act
sometimes but what is the
[Music]
alternative
I'm extremely proud to introduce you to
our newest brand partner on check out
their lineup of super comfortable sleek
and durable pieces for yourself at
[Music]
on.com well I'm glad that you took the
time to do this today this will not be a
five minute junk it type interview
hopefully well even better I love love a
deep sit down so I've been really
looking forward to this yeah cool we met
under very unusual circumstances about a
year and a half ago at a at an event
hosted by Google on the island of
Sicily where I don't know that I've ever
experienced such a cute impostor
syndrome in my life I just remember
showing up at like the opening dinner
and just feeling like the biggest fish
out of water of all time and I went
alone like my wife didn't come I was
there by myself I didn't know anybody it
was terrifying for me and at some
point I just sat down with you and John
and I'm embarrassed to admit that like I
didn't know who you were but I was like
they look like nice people and I sat
down I was like can I can I eat with you
guys and you created this really warm
welcome comfort zone for me so first I
just want to thank you for that you and
John together are such a beautiful warm
special couple
and you definitely uh made me feel a lot
better in that weird experience well I
felt the exact same way I was in the
midst of treatment with no eyebrows no
eyelashes no
hair and it was my first trip since
getting sick again so I was nervous on a
number of levels in addition to the
impostor syndrome right and I had a wig
that had been gifted to me and I've
never really worn a wig before but I was
like this is good gole these are
important people I have to blend in I
was miserable the whole first night my
head hurt the wig was too tight and I
went back to my room and I ripped it off
and threw it in my bag and I was like I
don't care how fancy pants of an event
this is the next time we have a dinner
I'm going out without my wig and I think
that was the dinner where we sat across
from each other and I felt like the kid
who walks into the high school cafeteria
and has forgotten to get dressed because
I felt completely naked with my bald
head but that's the funny thing about
those experiences is everyone assumes
that everyone else somehow feels at ease
or knows more people than they do but I
think in this case those people all did
know each other it is the Star Chamber
where you know they're all hanging out
doing whatever on fancy yachts and stuff
like that yeah well we were not part of
that I've never been on a yacht in my
life in watching the movie which we're
going to talk about it's such a
beautiful beautiful offering and you
know what a what a gift to the world so
thank you for that we're going to talk
about it but I couldn't help but
wonder where you were in your cancer
experience when you showed up in Sicily
so it was right after getting the second
diagnosis that the cancer had returned
yes I was deep in it I had just had my
second bone marrow transplant I had just
learned that even though the transplant
had worked I would be in treatment
indefinitely which was a really
challenging thing for me to wrap my head
around you know and everything from
fundraising slogans to conversations
with friends the goal is always to get
to the Cure and that wasn't happening
for me and that word
indefinite um
presented a mental Challenge in a way
much more so than a physical one of how
do I not only survive but how do I
actually figure out how to live in the
midst of this because surviving inde
definitely did not feel like an option
right there's a lot packed into what you
just shared that I want to tease out but
I think before we go any further I think
it would be um meaningful if you could
just recap the history of your
experience with getting sick at a very
young age and and kind of provide a
little bit of context yeah so I
graduated from college in 2010 10 and
Was preparing to enter the real world as
they like to say in college graduation
speeches and I had dreams of becoming a
journalist I wanted to be a war
correspondent although the question of
how to actually do that was unclear but
I think like a lot of people especially
young people I had this sense of time
time to figure out who I was time to
figure out
what I wanted to do in the
world but as it turned out I did not
have endless time I mean none of us do
but it was you know a a shocking
realization at 22 to be confronted with
my mortality in the form of a leukemia
diagnosis that's a period of time in
which we feel sort of invincible and our
relationship with time is extremely
different there's just tons of time to
live your life do the fun things build
your career and the Horizon is so far in
the distant future that it doesn't even
really compute and you were sort of
robbed of that typical conventional
experience and confronted with a very
different relationship with time what
does a future look like when it's so
uncertain yeah yeah and it really felt
like a breach of contract with the
natural order of things to get such a
diet a diagnosis at that age and
overnight my whole world changed I lost
my job I was working as a pargal I lost
my apartment I moved back home into my
childhood bedroom in Upstate New York
and began shuttling between there in the
hospital where I spent that first summer
living um as I
underwent you know various intensive
chemotherapy regimens only to learn that
none of them had worked and that in fact
my leukemia had become much more
aggressive and it was at that point that
it really occurred to me that there was
a good chance I was going to die and the
irony is you know far
greater
than the fear of death or the harrowing
side effects of this treatment what
perplexed me more was this idea that I
had spent my whole life preparing for a
life in a way the goal of young
adulthood is to be independent and yet I
was as dependent on caregivers as I'd
ever been from the time you know that I
was a toddler and I think what was
really hard for me to wrap my head
around was that you know I hadn't
figured out who I wanted to be but all
of a sudden there was this urgency to do
exactly that it also confronted you with
the limits of what it means to be an
ambitious young person like you're very
ambitious person and very accomplished
at a young age and like many people like
most people had dreams and goals and and
those were quite lofty for you and
suddenly that that rug gets pulled out
from underneath you and it shifts your
relationship with meaning in terms of
like yeah who am I if I can't be a
striver yeah if my life is not about
climbing a certain kind of ladder which
brings you into the present moment and
creates you know a very kind of
confusing space for anybody let alone a
young mind absolutely I think you know
in this culture where we prioritize
hustle and output and productivity I was
like a lot of my friends my entire sense
of selfworth was wrapped up in my
ability to succeed and I remember going
into the hospital that first summer I
packed you know pajamas the usual things
but I also packed like War and Peace and
every book in the Canon that I hadn't
yet read and announced to my parents
that I was going to use the summer in
the hospital to read through the
remainder of the Canon and I had all
these lofty ideas of what it's like to
go through Cancer Treatment from just
watching people in movies and
documentaries and on social media you
know people who go on to run marathons
and to start research foundations and in
that first year none of that happened
for me I was
completely stripped down I felt like not
only laid bare but almost larvel I
couldn't do anything I was angry I
remember at some point in the summer
closing the blinds to my hospital room
and I was one of the lucky patients who
had a view of Central Park which seems
like it would have been a nice thing to
have but it was too painful for me to
look outside the window because I would
watch these people going to work I would
watch you know young couples making out
on park benches and it was this reminder
that the world was moving on and I was
profoundly stuck and I didn't know what
to do with myself I didn't know what to
do with that rage that sense of defeat I
didn't know who I was when I wasn't
striving and it was the best thing that
ever happened to me
talk a little bit more about that piece
like why was it the best thing and what
did you learn from having to put your
ambition up on a
shelf
so I spent my days trying to set the
world record for the number of Grace
Anatomy episodes watched consecutively
that was my big fin TV I'm going to set
a record yeah exactly and I was you know
I was angry and my parents were really
worried not just about my physical
health but my mental health which is a
piece of the illness equation that I
don't think we focus enough on and
around that time a friend came up with
this idea of a 100 day project and the
premise was really simple we were each
going to do one creative act a day for a
100 days and so my dad who grew up in
Tunisia decided to write one childhood
memory every day and then a little nod
to a,1 nights he did 101
childhood memories that he compiled into
a little booklet and gave to me and my
brother at the end that's really
beautiful yeah my mom who's an artist
painted one small ceramic tile every day
and she at the end of the project
assembled them into a shield and hung it
above my bed did she do the tiles that
are in your house no she didn't but I do
have that shield and she made me a
second Shield when I had my recurrence
two years ago although the second Shield
is made out of hundreds of woven
Hospital bracelets from the last few
years and I was really reluctant to
participate in this project you know
when you're in a hospital bed people are
always pressuring you to be positive to
stay strong to find the silver lining
and all you know those pressures made me
want to punch everyone who walked into
my hospital room in the face I did not
want to make something meaningful out of
this experience I just didn't want it be
happening at all so for my project I
kept the bar very low and I decided to
keep a journal I was going to write in
it every day uh didn't matter how long
sometimes it was many pages occasionally
it was one word often the FW uh which
was all I could summon but something
interesting started to happen in that
process of keeping a journal and I
realized I was using the journal as a
kind of reporter's pad I was writing
about like the fellow patients I was
befriending a guy few a few doors down
for me his name was Dennis went on a
hunger strike when uh the meal Trace
kept arriving with the food still frozen
you know just weird little details
overheard Snippets of conversation by
the nurses station
and without realizing it
I was in a sense stepping into the role
of a war correspondent and Reporting
from the front lines of my hospital bed
and it was this moment for me and it was
a gradual moment um of
realizing that within these limitations
these bodily limitations that I had
there were things that I could do from
my hospital bed and much later that
became that journal became the source
material um for the New York Times
column I wrote called life Interrupted
which is my first time ever being
published yeah yeah yeah um that's an
amazing story in and of itself and I I
want to get to that but just I want to
stay here for a moment I'm curious
around the relationship like the the
necessity of finding an anchor to kind
of ground you like I can do this like I
can make this my job and I can approach
it like a professional War correspondent
and there's some sense of Safety and
Security in knowing well at least I have
this and this is something that I can
control amidst the chaos and the many
things that are well beyond your control
at that time yeah I mean there's so many
things about the experience of being
sick that can leave you feeling
powerless just think about that
clinician patient relationship they
enter the room in a lab coat you're in a
back
hospital gown sitting on a table and
it's very hard to feel empowered it's
very hard to hold on to a sense of self
when you're seeding so much control to
your medical team to your caregivers to
the everchanging treatment protocols and
so I had to find forms of agency that I
could hold on to and for me you know
that started with journaling and and
became writing um but I realized it was
essential
to my own ability to endure whatever the
next day was going to bring that I had
these little anchors these touchstones
that brought me back to myself
throughout the day going into the
hospital thinking okay I have to get
this thing treated I'm going to bring
all these books I'm going to be
productive I'm going to you know muscle
my way through this experience and then
I'll get back to my life and then
realizing the treatments aren't working
you're headed towards these experimental
treatments your mortality becomes you
know a very kind of visceral present
experience for you creating a
disorientation around what your future
might look like or if you might even
have one butts up against all of these
traditional narratives that we have
around illness terminal illness and in
particular very specifically with cancer
like the Nares around cancer and the
languaging around cancer is you go to
war with it this is a battle it's a very
kind of
masculine um framing of how you navigate
this disease set against a backdrop of
this hero's journey expectation like you
go through this you come out the other
side somehow you're able to extract
meaning from that that makes you a more
integrated whole person in the world and
you took issue with these narratives and
decided to confront them in your writing
to try to figure out a space that made
sense for what you were experiencing
specifically so talk a little bit about
arriving at that and you know how you
kind of came to a place of of of wanting
to share the truth the vulnerable truth
of what you were experiencing as a Sal
to other people who might be
experiencing something
similar yeah so let me first go on
record and say that I do not read any of
those books I have yet to read war in
peace what that experience
of um being the opposite of productive
taught me was what happens when you
allow yourself to lie fallow and you do
things for me it was keeping that
journal that you're doing purely for
yourself without any expectation of
anything coming out of it of anyone ever
reading it um and there was a sense of
creative
Liberation that I felt when I tapped
into that space um and I realized that
there was likely if I did survive this
illness never going to be another time
in my life where I wouldn't have that
outside expectation of output and that I
should use this time to experiment and
play and
try things you know within my
limitations that I could do just for the
hell of it and
so when I started to think about writing
for a larger audience it was the very
opposite of the hero's journey I wanted
to push against that because you know I
think so much is there's so much
pressure to be someone who suffers well
whether you have cancer or you don't to
be stoic and brave and wise and
transformed before you even emerged from
the belly of the Beast and I found that
pressure exhausting I found it deeply
dangerous and harmful it glosses over
all of you know the very real
challenges of enduring a trauma which an
illness is and having to navigate that
experience of re
where you're trying to figure out who
you are on the other side of it you know
Tony
Morrison has this beautiful line where
she says if you want to read a book and
it doesn't exist then you must write it
and so I wanted to speak to that
experience of being in the in between
place where you don't know who you are
where Everything feels messy where
you're
mired an uncertainty to give ink to the
things that felt incredibly hard to talk
about with my family and my friends to
talk about everything from the sense of
guilt uh that can come with being sick
and that feeling of being a burden to
the insanity of navigating our health
care System to what it feels like to be
falling in love when you're falling sick
and so that's what I tried to do it
wasn't the story I ever thought I would
be writing I'd always imagined myself as
someone who would help other people tell
their stories but I found the first
person to be an interesting challenge to
kind of resist what we think the story
should be and to keep pushing for the
truth beneath the truth beneath the
truth as human beings we're we're
pattern Seekers right right and we love
the before and the after and you know
sort of right angles and and clean lines
and and you're experience was one of
saying I don't feel like there's a
before and an after I'm in between I'm
in this Lial space where everything is
murky and gray and unclear and I don't
know if there is an after and if there
is it's not going to conform to this
hero's journey narrative and not
interested in being the the sort of um
inspirational Survivor here in the
traditional sense and so that creates
its own crisis of meaning like what does
that mean and I think the impulse to
really dive into that and to explore it
is an exercise in the messiness of Being
Human like even if you haven't
experienced cancer or even a great
tragedy uh our lives are are not really
ones of befores and Afters they're
they're marked by constant gradual
Transitions and most of it is about the
gray and the confusion and the in
between and one of the really cool
things that you kind of
identified in the process of exploring
this is the importance of of ritualizing
these these transitions like to really
honor them with ritual and appreciate
them for what they are rather than deny
them and say well I'll just wait until
I'm in that after space that I'm
attached to with
expectations yeah I mean the image that
always comes to mind is a ceiling caving
in and when the ceiling has caved in on
you you no longer assume structural
stability instead you have to learn to
live along fault lines and so when I
emerged from treatment after almost four
years I had expected that sense of being
on the other side and I knew how lucky I
was to be alive out of the 10 Young
cancer comrades I befriended during my
time and treatment only two of us were
alive at that point and yet I felt so
lost I could barely breathe and I spent
a year feeling completely stuck when I
emerged from
treatment I had no idea what to do with
my myself I had no idea how to carry
that wreckage I was desperately trying
to move on in all the ways that you know
we think we should move on um only to
realize that moving on was a myth I
wasn't going to be able to
compartmentalize you know this fouryear
period of my life I wasn't going to be
able to skip back to the person I'd been
pre-diagnosis you have the hard wiring
to be the striver but then on top of
that the kind of social or societal
expectations like okay this is in the
past now what are you doing now
absolutely the day I had the my chemo
Port removed from my chest I remember
getting a slew of text messages from
people saying congratulations like you
can start your life now this is amazing
but unlike when you're in treatment
there were no you know medical
protocols or 12 setep programs to help
me Find My Way Forward after this
illness I felt like I'd had this Cavalry
surrounding me for 4 years and I was
suddenly on my own to figure it out and
it was really isolating and really hard
and to get back to the idea of ritual I
started thinking about how you know we
have all these rights of Passage be it
funerals or weddings or baby showers
that help ease that transition between
no longer and not yet and in the world
of illness there wasn't a ritual there
wasn't a right of passage to help you
find your way your place back among the
living and that I was going to need to
create that for
myself every athlete I know is going to
tell you that having the right gear is
key to Performance if what you're
wearing is poorly crafted it's just
going to put distance between you and
those goals you've set you owe it to
yourself to invest in the best and the
best is on I'm obsessed with the cloud
Ultra great on the trails and I just got
the new nextg Cloud Stratus 3 for the
road I'm loving those but an also has
this incredible line of lightweight high
performance apparel that it's just
beyond anything I've previously dawned
it's like this second to none Second
Skin I love to rock the sweat wicking
Ultra te and the ultra shorts which have
this pocket right at the base of the
spine that perfectly Ang anchors your
phone no jiggle I'm just so proud to
partner with on and I love their vision
for the future where their gear is
engineered for
circularity so check out their amazing
lineup of super comfortable sleek and
durable pieces for yourself at
on.com at some point though you get this
diagnosis of PTSD which is sort of a
light bulb moment like oh yeah what I
just endured was incredibly traumatic
and that helps create a frame for you to
put the pieces back together on some
level yeah for whatever reason I thought
of PTSD as
something that's reserved you know for
more veterans or people who've
experienced some kind of acute violence
and in part you know because of this
hero's journey Arc that is foed on
cancer patients and this expectation of
constant gratitude it never occurred to
me that I was suffering from PTSD
although it sounds like the most obvious
thing in the world and it made me
realize that in spite of having that
diagnosis there wasn't much in the way
of support at least not you know 10
years ago when I was going through this
that's surprising to me yeah you hear
about cancer support groups but I would
think that there is a whole
infrastructure around cancer survival
and that that very unique experience of
what do you do now where groups of
people would get together and share what
their challenges are that doesn't exist
I think it exists now more and more but
not enough uhhuh and so I really felt on
my own and had to create that support
group for myself right so what I ended
up doing was writing to some of the many
strangers who'd written to me with
stories of aftermath and their own life
interruptions and asking if I could
visit them before we get to that though
I mean you're like a lifetime journaler
like like journaling is big deal right I
have more questions about that but you
you initiate this process when when
you're in the hospital that ends up as a
Blog I'm interested in how that ended up
as a column in the New York Times not
only a column in the New York Times but
also an Emmy award-winning
column so when I got the date for my
first bone marrow
transplant my doctor told me Point Blank
that I had about a 35% chance of
surviving
it and I had about a month and a half
before I was going to undergo that
transplant and so that sense of
finitude came crashing down on me and I
realized that there were lots of things
that I wanted to do that I might not be
able to do but writing had always been
this great love of mine and I decided I
was going to take the contents of this
journal and turn them into essays and so
I started a WordPress blog from my
hospital room I watched YouTube videos
on how to build it it was pretty you
know basic stuff and I'm sure that that
first week my readership consisted of
solely my parents and my grandmother but
I took it really seriously I would write
every single day and it felt really good
to have a job to do other than just
being a patient um and it was that sense
of agency that I've been craving for a
long time and about two or three weeks
into writing that blog it started to get
passed around and shared and and I got
an email from an editor at the New York
Times and later a phone call um in which
she asked me if I might be interested in
writing an essay for the
paper and I thanked her and said I
wasn't interested in writing an essay
and then I took a deep breath and I told
her that what I really wanted to do was
to write a weekly column From The
Trenches of treatment because so often
illness narratives were written from the
perspective and vant point of someone
who survived and it was a very different
experience to write from that place of
not knowing that place of deep
uncertainty and then I said that I also
hoped that there could be a video series
accompanying it because I
knew how hard it could be to read when
you're sick and that I wanted this
project to feel as inclusive as possible
and I went on and on and on and you know
this would have seemed wildly presump
yeah you're 2 at this point 22 22 right
to pre-diagnosis want from the global
paper of record yes audacious doesn't
quite capture like the magnitude of of
that request you know without ever
having being published before like
here's what I need in order to go
forward with this exactly but that's the
thing about you know staring your
mortality straight in the eyes every
other fear uh pales and
and I had this of limited
time and in a weird way I
think cancer had made me Brazen and I
felt like I needed to shoot my shot
because what was the worst that was
going to happen it couldn't be any worse
than whatever it was I was about to come
up against and to my surpris she said
okay we'll try it for a couple of
installments and see how it goes m
and then I went oh [__] I don't know if
I can actually this self imposed job
just became a real job totally and
you're in your hospital bed yeah what
happens when you have an actual deadline
not uh you know an imagined deadline and
you're not feeling up to it there's a
photo of me in the bone marrow
transplant unit where I have my laptop
on my knees and a vomit bucket under one
arm and I'm crying not because I'm going
through the most brutal chemotherapy
that you can go through but because I'm
worried that I'm going to miss my
deadline and that might sound unhealthy
but I actually think it was a really
necessary you know shift in perspective
for me because I
wasn't you know wallowing and whatever
was happening to me I was figuring out
how I could participate in the world
from my room so the Tentacles from this
column reach far and wide
you're suddenly on the receiving end of
a lot of people who are being impacted
by what you're sharing and you're
reading all of this and taking note of
these stories to bring this back to what
you were sharing earlier about this
decision when you finally are back out
in the world to go and visit these
people who had written to you yeah and
you know I think it's important to
say that you know for me I I wrote These
missive in a void I sent them out not
really expecting anything to come out
and return and I'd been so deeply
isolated I spent I had spent that whole
last year I think I spent eight
cumulative months in isolation in the
hospital and one of the very first
letters I received was from a death row
prisoner by the name of Quinton Jones
who'd read a column I'd written where I
described um
what I called my Inc
canceration and that experience of
isolation and he had never been sick a
day in his life he used to do 1,000
push-ups every day to start start off
his morning he related to that
experience of
confinement of you know confronting your
mortality and not
knowing when the sword was going to fall
and so I received all kinds of letters a
lot of them from people dealing with
illnesses but aot lot of them dealing
with all kinds of Life interruptions and
so to fast
forward a couple of years during that
really challenging year where I was done
with
treatment I was on paper better but off
paper feeling worse than I'd ever felt I
began responding to these individuals
including Quinton Jones and asked them
if I could visit them and I ended up
embarking well first learning how to
drive right right like a good New Yorker
you never learned how to drive well you
were also like a good New Yorker stuck
in the hospital for my adult life never
learning how to drive and embarking on a
solo 15,000 mile road trip to go and
visit about two dozen of these strangers
and to ask them about their experiences
of aftermath to ask them you know how it
was that they
were healing and and moving forward from
their own particular
traumas you go and visit little GQ right
that's that's what he goes by the guy in
death brow Quinton Jones yep little GQ
yeah you visit him you visit basically a
survivalist yes compound where a woman
had written to you yes which is
interesting and then this young girl
unique also which I was very struck by
her yeah yeah and you know I think we
live in a loneliness epidemic but when
you're
suffering especially in this age of
Instagram where everyone is posting a
highlights real of their life there can
be this sense that you are the only
person who is suffering in that
particular way and that everyone else
seems to be able to somehow survive and
to get it together better than you and
so it was a pretty you know
extraordinary experience for
me after spending so many years in
confinement to thrust myself not only
out into the greater expanses of the
world but onto the porches and into the
guest rooms of these perfect strangers
because I think what happens
when we dare to share our most
unvarnished
stories of vulnerability is that of
course we learn that we're more alike
than we are different it is the secret
sauce to connection honestly and it's
the thing that we're most scared of and
yet it's the most powerful Salve to
unite us yeah and as a writer you're
deeply connected to that but I'm curious
as to whether in the process of of your
Journal then becoming a Blog and then
becoming a column and then ultimately a
book um if you struggled with how much
you should share or what that kind of
vulnerability equation should look like
absolutely I mean it being vulnerable is
not comfortable for me I don't know that
it's comfortable for anybody I had a
Post-It note on my desk when I returned
from that road trip and began writing
that said if you want to write a good
book write what you don't want others to
know about you if you want to write a
great book write what you don't want to
know about
yourself my first drafts are often full
of lies not intentional lies but
aspirational lies here's how I'd prefer
to be perceived yeah or here's the story
I want to believe and so I know that I'm
doing my job right
when I feel that sense of discomfort
Cheryl St also offered a little nugget
of advice to you that's related to those
Post-it
noes so before I went on that road trip
I was actually interviewing Cheryl for a
piece that ended up being killed so it
never came out um about mentors and at
the end of our conversation
inadvertently she became you know a
mentor to to me when she asked me what
it was that I was working on and I said
I really want to write a book but I
don't want to write about illness I'm
trying to move on from that I don't want
to be a sick person I don't want to be
pigeon hold as a sick person whatever it
is I write about it's got to be about
something other than elist and she said
to me the funny thing about that is that
when I went to go right wild you know
famous Memoir about hiking the Pacific
Crest Trail I told myself whatever it is
that I write about I don't want to write
about my dead mother right um and of
course you know wild is the story of
that hike but it's also the story of
grieving her dead mother and the point
that I took away from that is that as
long as there is a question that is
pushing at the edges of your mind as
long as there's something that you're
trying to figure out you have no
business trying to avoid it until you've
written your way through it and so my
book between two kingdoms was about this
road trip but of course it was all about
the
struggle of not only falling ill but
figuring out who I was and the aftermath
of that and figuring out how to carry
you know what had happened forward with
meh that book ends up on the New York
Times best seller list like forever I
don't know how many weeks how many week
a long time right it's probably going to
back now because of the movie which is
amazing and on the heels of that you you
do a Ted Talk on the main stage at Ted
that's sort of an encapsulated version
of of of the book and what you've just
been sharing um that goes on to get I
don't know 19 million views or something
like that one of the most watched TED
talks and in reflecting on your book and
and that Ted Talk they're very much a a
capsule of what you were experiencing
thing at a particular phase of your
relationship with your illness and your
life and your life is different now I'm
curious when you look back on the book
The Ted Talk where your head was at
where your soul and your spirit were at
at that time how does that match up with
what you're experiencing
now so about two weeks before between
two kingdoms came out I got a letter
from
GQ saying that he had gotten a date he
had gotten an execution date and this
was after you know spending more than
half of his life almost 25 years on
death row and I just felt my stomach
fall when I heard that and so when I
went into my virtual book tour because
this is during the
pandemic
I decided that I was going to try to use
these speaking events to amplify his
situation as much as possible and what
ended up happening was that you know
through these speaking events there was
one person in the audience who was the
partner of a big Law Firm who ended up
representing him pro bono there was
another person who helped with PR and I
got thrust into this multi-month
clemency effort to
try to get Quin
a death sentence changed to a life
sentence and he was the first person to
say that he belonged behind bars for the
rest of his life but that he had also
spent those 25 years on death row
Reckoning with what he'd done taking
accountability for it asking forgiveness
for the murder that he committed and you
know working to become the best version
of the man he could be
and in the weeks leading up um to what
ultimately was a filled execution effort
I did not sleep I could not sleep I was
working nonstop because especially
having gone through illness it seemed so
unacceptable to me that if there was a
choice to spare someone's life that that
choice not be made this is a very
roundabout way of answering your
question but on the day of his execution
he was granted a 4-Hour phone call and
he spent those four hours on the phone
with John and me and I remember saying
to
him I am so sorry I feel
like we failed you and uh he said you
haven't failed me and the reality is
that even though it's not the outcome
we'd hoped for it's this feels like the
greatest success that I could have
imagined
because I never experienced love growing
up and in the last few weeks I felt more
loved by more people than I've ever felt
in my entire life and I can walk into
that execution chamber knowing that I've
loved and that I've been loved and
that's enough and the next day I
couldn't get out of bed which seemed
understandable uh but later I still
couldn't get out of bed and 3 weeks
later that remained true and at first I
attributed that fatigue to the
exhaustion of working on Quinn's case to
the sadness of losing him in the way
that we did but something about that
fatigue began to feel earily familiar
and ultimately after a couple of weeks
of being misdiagnosed I learned that
after nearly a decade in remission my
leukemia was back back and the irony is
that you know my book is all about
navigating the in between and I found
myself thrust in an in between Place
unlike any I'd been in before John and I
were at what felt like the peak of Our
Lives it was one of those moments where
you know various projects that we'v been
working on for years and years and years
were all coming to fruition and it was
supposed to be this moment of
celebration of ease and it became the
very opposite of that you know once
again we packed up our things we left
our home we relocated to the city to be
close to slone kering where I received
my treatment and it was this moment in
our lives of extreme contrast because
the same day I started doing
chemotherapy John learned that he'd been
nominated for a historic number of
Grammys 11 gramys and we realized that
we were about to embark on a roller
coaster or actually to call it a roller
coaster would be an insult to roller
coasters I expected that book coming out
I expected whatever came after to feel
like the beginning of a new chapter and
in some ways it felt like an old one
right yeah that's what I'm getting at
it's sort of like yeah okay I wrote this
book about yeah embracing
uncertainty uh but I did that like
that's done that's in the past now I'm
moving here so it's sort of like I did
that piece I acknowledged
it but I'm still in a new I'm going to
be in a new chapter right now so there's
a there's a sort of weird blind denial
of the very thesis that formed the book
and and kind of how you were known
public Al and then you got this
Reckoning or reminder that you had to
once again inhabit that space and it's
it's very human you know it's very it's
sort of like okay I did that like
enough and did you have a sense before
that
diagnosis that despite being told like
here's the percentage chance that you'll
survive or perish as a result of this
disease was there still a sense of
having it placed in your rear view
mirror and anything regarding cancer in
the future was purely theoretical
because you wanted to go get that biopsy
when everybody told you like hey you
don't really need to do that there was
something inside of you that that
compelled you to do that and had you not
done that you know you would be in a
very different place I think I mean I
couldn't shake that fear of relapse for
years and years and years and years long
after it stopped making sense that I
would be so afraid but by the time the
book came out I did feel past it we were
making all kinds of plans to have you
know babies and get married and all the
other you know typical things that you
start to think about in your 30s and to
add to that I was getting messages and
notes every day from readers of the book
saying you know seeing you thriving 10
years out and so healthy gives me the
hope that I can too so the was that
added layer of it and were you able to
hear that and own that or were you like
resistant to that being voed on you I
resisted it because there was something
inside of me that fell off I wanted to
receive it I wanted to believe
it but as is often the case when you're
falling sick there's a kind of
schizophrenia that takes hold of your
mind where you
you know you're living a split reality
and I felt that you know I'd go to sleep
and write in my journal and find myself
writing the exact same things I'd
written when I was first falling sick
but still in denial of it and what
troubled that even more was that when I
went to seek medical treatment I was
told that I was totally fine I'd had
Lyme disease and so they attributed my
low blood counts to that um and I'd had
an experience of a year-long
misdiagnosis my first time getting sick
where I had received every diagnosis
from anxiety and depression to burnout
syndrome and once again I found myself
being confronted with you know various
people telling me essentially that I was
fine when I did not feel fine but I had
the fortune or I guess the
misfortune of experience and I pushed
for that biopsy and even on the day that
I went to get that biopsy I had asked a
friend of mine who is very busy uh to
take the day off to come with me and
when we arrived the nurse said we're
just doing this biopsy to ease your
anxiety you can still change your mind
um and I felt totally embarrassed like I
was being melodramatic like I was some
kind of hypochondriac and also
embarrassed that I had asked this very
busy important friend of mine to come
all this way and so you're not going to
say it but the very busy important
friend uh is is the great Liz Gilbert so
it's like these are your writing mentors
you got Cheryl straight and you got Liz
Gilbert I mean it doesn't get any better
than doesn't get
any I've been riched in mentors but Liz
feels like the kind of person that shows
up for her friends in this kind of way
like this is what she does she really is
and so you know as i' like like to say
that I push for that biopsy for myself
but the reality is I push for that
biopsy cuz I wanted it to feel like a
good use of her day
off which is pretty pathetic but I'd
also learn the hard way that you know
you need to advocate for yourself when
something is a miss you have to push for
answers and the worst thing that can
happen is that you're wrong and you get
to go on and live your life
although in this case I was right though
I wish I hadn't been and about 3 days
later I got the phone call from my
oncologist who was shocked and in tears
and said that leukemia is back and it's
far more
aggressive and what did that feel like
to hear that I think I
felt total
shock and total Terror
and weirdly after that came a sense of
relief because this thing that I feared
most more than any other fear had
actually happened and
now all there was to do was to move into
action and that might seem like a
strange response but when you've spent
many
months feeling that something is deep
wrong and being told that nothing is
wrong you start to feel like you're
going crazy and so I felt relief to be
believed and relief to hopefully be able
to do something about it and I guess
relief to
have had the experience to know how I
wanted to approach this bout of illness
differently but of course I felt total
Terror my parents were living in Tunisia
which is where they currently live and I
remember feeling so afraid to call them
and to tell them because I
knew that a diagnosis like this doesn't
just implode the patients life but it
implodes the lives of everyone around
you yeah that's a weird juxtaposition of
feeling
Vindicated but also feeling terrified
yeah like I was right that feels good
uhoh here we go again I'm probably gonna
die and this is where the movie opens
basically
yeah so American symphony is just this
you know really beautiful
exploration of your life and Jon's life
individually and together it's really an
excavation of what it means to
live a creative life to be in a creative
collaborative
relationship to navigate
hardship but whereas your book and
everything that kind of had
preceded this phase of your life with
respect to your own creative output was
really about these Lial spaces these
gray
areas American Symphony in this next
chapter is really about extreme
juxtapositions it's about Peak
experiences high and
low it's not so much about the gray as
it is the Ping ponging back and forth
between these extremes that most people
in their life will never experience you
know either the kind of highs that Jon
was writing or the lows that you were
experiencing just simply trying to
survive and it creates this really
unique dynamic between the two of you
that's absolutely captivating and
mesmerizing but
also this beautiful kind of living
example of of one of your mantras which
is how do you make survival a creative
act yeah how did the movie Come Together
American Symphony
initially arose from a conversation John
and Matt had over dinner John had worked
on his previous film the first wave
about the covid-19 pandemic and scored
parts of it and when Matt asked him what
he was working on he said he was working
on the symphony this project that had
been in the works for many many years
and was finally going to premiere for
one night only at Carnegie Hall and he
and Matt decided to make a short process
film about the bringing to life of that
Symphony and before
Matt even began shooting I learned that
the leukemia was back and John was
nominated for this record number of
Grammys and as Matt likes to say if
you end up with the story that you began
with then you're not doing your job
right you weren't listening along the
way and
so you know before the cameras began
rolling we all realized there was a very
different version of the story to tell
but as you might imagine I felt very
hesitant about the idea of letting a
camera into our private lives especially
at such a difficult moment both John and
me are fiercely private people which
might sound like an odd thing to say as
someone who's written largely in the
first person for my entire career but
usually I'm the one doing the writing
and usually whatever it is that I'm
writing I have you know the time to
figure out what is the draft I want to
write for myself and what is the draft
that I want to share with the world and
so it took a real leap of faith to let
Matthew heinerman our
director into our lives in this way and
Matt isn't just your regular filmmaker
he woke up with us and went to bed with
us every night not literally but he was
there with the camera and ended up
amassing about 1,500 hours of footage
over the course of this 7mon period and
the truth is when we started filming
this
documentary I really
didn't know what the story was going to
be none of us did I didn't know if I was
going to survive long enough to see the
documentary but we knew knew John and I
knew that we wanted to capture these
extremes and maybe you know what we were
living through was more extreme than
what the average person might be living
through but we all have to hold the
duality of The Human Condition we all
have experiences in our lives where
we're holding the astonishingly brutal
Facts of Life um with the beautiful ones
in the same palm and we felt that that
was a worthy experience to document even
if we didn't know exactly what it was
going to become right the fear and the
uncertainty of not knowing where this
new chapter with your illness was going
to take you and the hesitancy around
sharing that butting up
against both of you being artists both
of you being expressive being being who
who Find meaning and purpose in in
sharing your unique experiences and also
as somebody who has a profound
understanding of the power of
vulnerability to heal and connect as we
were talking about earlier creates its
own tension you know like okay well I
say all these things and and you know my
my whole kind of Mo is sharing my life
but now here I am in a very different
place do I really want to do this yeah
and I remember saying to Matt early on I
don't want to be a part of this film if
my
story serves the purpose of being the
dramatic Counterpoint to John's meteoric
success I didn't want my illness to be
narrativized for dramatic benefit which
it easily could have been in the hands
of a less thoughtful less skilled
filmmaker and so we had a lot of
conversations we had conversations every
day every week uh where we had to
continually reassess this is something
we want to keep filming is is something
we want to keep doing what was off
limits nothing
nothing Julie what would you say to
somebody who comes to you and says you
know what I find your lifestyle or the
way that you eat really aspirational but
I'm too busy I just don't have time I
don't want to be cracking open cookbooks
and trying to learn a new skill when I'm
already exhausted after a long day how
do you guide this person where should
they go the plant power meal planner is
really really such an amazing value it
is under $2 a week and for that it gives
you this inspiration knowhow and
thousands of recipes to create the
plant-based meals that you crave in your
own life so it's so amazing to be able
to log on on to the plant power meal
planner and get the recipes the
ingredients uh the shopping list and
then the support from all of the coaches
that we have available to answer all of
your questions so join us in eating more
healthy vibrant plant-based meals and to
Kickstart our health intentions this New
Year we're offering you $20 off a
oneyear membership with the code power
20 throughout the entire month of
January to learn more and to sign up go
to meals. Rich roll.com again that's
promo code power20 for $20 off at
meals.
roll.com
I mean you really do get the feel that
he's living with you I mean we are
getting a bird's eye view of your daily
life and the truth is you know as
uncomfortable as it was to open
ourselves up in this way especially for
me where I was feeling my worst looking
my worst I also knew that we had an
opportunity on a whole new scale to pull
back the curtain and to show that
Duality and that if we were going to do
it we had to do it right right which is
to say that nothing could be off
limits so John is somebody that you met
when you were 13 at like juliard summer
camp or something right band camp you
played a standup base as a young person
um John was this musician from New
Orleans you had struck up a friendship
as as young people you reconnected when
I think you were a senior in high school
and he was at juliard you bumped into
him on the subway he was playing music
do I have that right pretty much yeah I
think I was 16 what would have been I
would have been a junior in high school
I dropped out of high school and you had
kind of a spark moment shortly before
you left for Paris at a going away party
but you weren't really a couple until
you returned from Paris and kind of came
out the other side of your first chapter
with leukemia then you become this
couple and you end up getting married
the night before you go back into the
hospital which is quite extraordinary so
John John is getting involve with you
knowing full well all of the uncertainty
that this relationship presents yeah so
what does that say about who John is
like how do we understand John
batist what a question a very hard one
for me to answer just because you know
he's one of the most
expansive
surprising relentlessly unique
individuals that I've ever encountered
and we had been together you know for
about 9 years or something by the time I
got sick we'd been talking about getting
married but like a lot of couples during
the pandemic were talking about getting
married we figured we would wait until
it was safe enough to have a big
Gathering and the way that John put it
to me was he said we had a plan and we
are not going to let cancer get in the
way of that plan and so we decided you
know 24 hours before I entered the bone
marrow transplant unit and was you know
getting ready to be admitted to the
hospital for several weeks to throw
together a living room wedding which is
what we did and John rented a grand
piano for the night we had champagne and
fried chicken sandwiches as takeout and
we had this beautiful impromptu ceremony
we didn't even have wedding rings we had
twisty bread ties was ask what the the
backstory with the twisty tie Rings was
all about we had done everything we had
gotten a virtual marriage license
earlier that morning while I was in the
O getting prepped for a port to be
implanted into my chest we had you know
rushed to throw together outfits and at
the 11th hour we realized we didn't have
wedding bands so that's where the bread
ties came from and it moved me so much
that this was his reaction I mean we
have you know the usual vows of in
sickness and in health and for us we
were starting that journey of marriage
deep in the in sickness part of those
vows and I remember the next morning
when I woke up
feeling such a sense of hope
that I think would have been really hard
for me to muster as I was getting ready
to go in the hospital because it wasn't
just a marriage it wasn't just a
celebration of who we were as a couple
but it felt like this act of optimism of
saying we are going to have a future and
I will get to exist in that
future he's a special guy that John I
mean in addition to just being absurdly
handsome you know he has a certain
unique Charisma about him but that
Charisma and he's a natural born
performer of course but there's a joy
and a gratitude and a and a
curiosity like when he is with somebody
he has that thing
where you feel like you're the center of
the universe when his attention is
focused on you but it's coming from a
really genuine place of of wanting to
understand people people you know like
it's quite a thing that he has and I
knew that about him long before we were
ever a couple when I first got sick and
I spent that summer in the hospital and
learned that all of the standard
chemotherapy treatments were working for
me that very same day John heard about
my leukemia diagnosis and he was in
rehearsal with this band and he brought
the whole band to the hospital
unannounced
Uninvited and put on a spontane concert
right there for me in my hospital room
and as The Sound of Music started to
filter started to filter into the
hallways of the hospital all of these
patients and doctors and nurses came out
of their rooms and everyone began to
dance and sing together and that's who
John is he shows up in the hardest
moments doesn't matter if he knows you
if he doesn't know you and he did that
for me that day and he continued to do
that for me again and again and again
long long before we were in a
relationship and so in a way you know
this response to the recurrence wasn't
surprising to me mhm he's that guy he's
the guy who says we're going to get
married today and we're going to make it
happen because moments like this make
you realize what really matters
meanwhile you go back into the hospital
and then he's just on an absolute rocket
ship like you know beyond anything that
mere mortals can understand like the Arc
of his career at this moment in time is
just at the peak of all Peak experiences
and we see much of that experience
through his eyes or as the viewer like
we're seeing him at the Grammys and all
these performances and traveling Etc he
comes
home what I don't feel like we see quite
enough of is
your internal experience of having to
process that your husband is off in the
world you know ex experiencing his best
self while you're in this powerless
condition unable to enjoy it with him
but also you know unable to be in your
own best expressive
self you know I've known John from the
time he was in braces I have watched him
work at has craft every single day and
when I found out I was sick
John immediate reaction was I want to
shut the machine down I want to be in
your hospital room I don't want to go to
the Grammys I don't want to go to work
and perform on the Le show I don't want
to be doing any of these things and it
felt unacceptable to me that he missed
out on this moment because of this cruel
twist of fate that I was going through
and so I very much pushed
him to you know do all of the things and
to seize whatever opportunities were
coming his way and I think in a sense it
was harder for him to be away he felt
like he was living this double life for
especially in the midst of so much Glitz
and Glam it felt
possible to care about all of that when
his head and his heart you know were
still in that hospital room but like
everything he came up with a a very
creative
solution to our being physically apart
and he began composing lullab for me he
would compose them every single day he
had a keyboard connected to his laptop
and I would listen to them on Loop for
hours and hours and hours because for
anyone who has spent a night in the
hospital you know it's not a restful
Place hospitals are noisy places there's
the constant beeping of IV machines the
wheezing of respirators the alarms that
go off whenever your condition abruptly
worsens and
so him composing these Lis was something
that brought him Solace they brought me
great Solace to listen to I love la
because they're so Elemental you know
most Lis are written in triple meter
because um they say that it mimics the
experience of a baby in the womb
listening to its mother's heartbeat
they're intended to soothe they're
intended to help you rest and they made
me feel like he was right there in that
room but I'll also add that I didn't
feel powerless in my hospital bed
I you know having gone through through
this before knew that the only way to
not only survive whatever it was that I
was going through but to really figure
out how to live and to thrive in the
midst of that was going to lie in my
ability to alchemize that isolation and
suffering into
something creative and meaningful and
maybe even beautiful and so that's what
I tried to do in my own way and what did
that look like specifically you were
painting so in a perfect world it would
have looked like writing and journaling
which are my two first loves but I
couldn't do that I was on a medication
that caused my vision to blur and double
and made it very difficult to see I was
trying to write a little bit using voice
cation but it was really frustrating and
really slow and so I picked up a
paintbrush uh which is something I
haven't done from the time I was a child
and I began to paint these literal fever
dreams that I was having these sort of
biblical surreal nightmarish visions of
myself with various animals that were
appearing to me and that's what I did I
remember you know one night in
particular um it was probably the most
challenging Day of My Life the closest
I've ever been to the veil I had three
simultaneous infections two of them in
my bloodstream and I had zero right
blood cells and I was as close to death
as I've ever been and to add insult to
injury my friend Liz Liz Gilbert was
taking care of my dog and she called me
that morning and it turned out that my
dog also had cancer and had to be put
down a couple of hours later and that
night I felt like I was falling apart in
a way where I wasn't
sure I'd be able to put myself back
together I was you know brought to my
knees in a way that I've never
experienced before and I felt so much
pain not only physical but psychic in a
way that felt
unendurable and I had this sudden vision
of a wooden
marionette being connected to strings to
four birds and being
lifted and I picked up my paintbrush and
I had this chant on repeating my head
which was I Release Control I surrender
to the flow and I painted that painting
in one fast furious breath and as I
started to paint the ropes connecting
the wooden marionette to the birds I
could feel my spine lifting I could feel
myself being lifted and that to me is
the power of creativity it's the power
to make something out of nothing to
transform the most brutal experiences
into something interesting and beautiful
and it feels like a kind of
magic that's really
powerful the catharsis of that too and
the and the the demand that you deepen
your surrender yeah that this will not
be like the time before yeah and you're
not going to be allowed to journal
because you did that last time you're
going to have to find a new way to
alchemize this
yeah and that process of surrender and
whatever relief you experienced as a
result of that like what ises
that what does that look like
spiritually does that have form for
you so you know my mom is is Catholic my
dad is
Muslim and my brother and I I like to
say grew up confused yeah as a result of
that so I've never you know participated
in organized religion I've never had an
easily
definable sense of Faith or spirituality
but I have through writing and painting
and my creative work
experience that sense of being a Channel
of submitting to something bigger than
myself and I've been humbled again and
again brutally so by this disease and so
I think for
me that experience of
surrender is the closest I've come to
feeling touched by a sense of divinity
and I think it's
also the only way to navigate that depth
of
uncertainty to acknowledge that you
don't know that you can't know whatever
is going to happen to you or to the
people you love
most and to try to tap into the mystery
of that and maybe even into the magic of
it if there's peace to be had it's going
to be found through that process of
extreme letting go yeah and then in
tandem with that to hearken back to Liz
it's your job to pull that idea out of
The Ether that's yours and Uniquely
Yours to give expression to a different
version of
myself might have fought against not
having access to the tools that I
learned which for me were writing and
journaling might have wallowed in that
but I knew you know from going through
this before that to fight that to to bug
up against that was going to be a recipe
for Endless frustration and
exhaustion and that again once again
when you let go of your striving and
your fighting and your
muscling things reveal themselves things
that you might not notice otherwise if
you're busy striving fighting and
musling your way through yeah when
you're in the allowing and you can be
that channel for the unconscious and the
Divine or the Beyond that's where the
real magic occurs and that requires a
certain level of surrender and John said
something in the movie that I thought
was really that really grabbed me about
that with respect to music which was
something about the inevitability of
music like when you hear a
song on some conscious or unconscious
level you kind of know what the next
note is going to be
so that it is something that actually
exists and your job as a musician is to
bring form to it but that it is not
yours it belongs to the universe or
whatever and I thought about that a lot
and I was like sometimes it'll be
surprising because the artist will
choose a different note when your brain
has an expectation that oh this is the
note that generally should follow this
yeah so you can play with those rules
but typically when you hear a song for
the first time time you kind of know a
nanc before you hear it where it's
taking you totally even if it surprises
you and I was thinking about how that
might apply to writing or to other you
know creative Pursuits like you
mentioned earlier you know what Cheryl
had shared to you about writing and you
find the writing and doing the thing
right you don't sit down with an idea of
what it is you do the thing and it
starts to tell you what it is totally
and perhaps there's an inevitability to
that as well
Robert Frost has a a beautiful line he
says no tears in the writer no tears in
the reader no surprise for the writer no
surprise for the
reader and I live by
that it's like if the thing that you're
trying to make does not surprise you
does not bring you to your knees in some
kind of way in the process of making it
then you can't expect that it will have
that effect on the people body else yeah
exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a
good note and also this idea that that
the writing down of something makes it
real in this kind of manifesting
sensibility right like an idea is an
idea but once you put pen to paper
something magical happens that just
allows it to become a little more real
or to take root in reflecting back upon
that experience when we were in Sicily
so one of the things that I was meant to
do during that trip was to interview
Rick Rubin in front of a group of people
so I had an early copy of his book The
creative act I read it on the plane on
the way to Sicily and I was very
impacted by that
book and I'm a big journaler myself I've
been doing it forever but I hadn't been
doing it consistently and I woke up the
first morning at that hotel and went out
on the veranda and journaled for the
first time in months and that journal
entry and the journaling that I began to
do as a result of that became the
outline of a book that I'm now writing
wow and I would not have realized or
thought that or expected that at the
time but it's just an example of how
that process works in the Arc of
creation and I think that you are
somebody who is a very powerful
manifestor somebody who has been
physically handicapped for a huge
portion of your adult life and yet at
the same time somehow managed to write a
New York Times best-selling book gotten
a column in the New York Times one in
Emmy like was on the Ted stage and now
you're you've got this documentary that
very well could get nominated or even
win an Oscar like it's insane you know
you're still a very young person like
that's an in
incredible resume of accomplishments and
then when you consider how much of your
adult life has been spent going in and
out of
hospitals it's quite a remarkable thing
so how do you think about manifestation
there's another line in the movie that
really it felt like a
throwaway statement in watching the
movie but it really stuck with me in a
big way which is right after you got
married and you guys are all hanging out
and John is talking about you and he
said something like oh when when I met
sulea she said we're going to change the
world was that when you were were 13 no
I think I was 20 you were like yeah
we're going to change the world but I
mean godamn like you guys you're well on
your way to doing that you've already
made a huge dent so I'm interested in
where not the ambition piece but the the
sense of self or the kind of mission
orientation that you have around that
that has you know fueled your your
creative works
the irony is that I don't think any of
those accomplishments would have
happened or been possible without The
Misfortune of being sick and and living
with so many
limitations I think you would have found
other ways though I think it's in you
whatever circumstances you would have
found yourself in you would have found a
way to turn that experience into this
creative act maybe so but
I also think I was someone who was a
striver I was a good student you know I
wanted to be a war
correspondent but you know because of
the way that I grew up I didn't
necessarily feel like that was a
practical path for me and so I was also
toying with the idea of law school and
trying to think about what might be oh
God most practical yeah we you're a
fellow recovering lawyer you know
getting sick
foreclosed a lot of those more
conventional paths and
possibilities to me and one thing I did
in that first year of getting sick was I
spent a lot of time researching and
reading about the very long history and
lineage of artists and musicians who've
been bedridden for one reason or another
and observing everyone from you know
freed to Koo who painted these her
famous self-portraits from bed after um
being left bedre in by a car accident or
matis when he got diagnosed with cancer
and attached a paintbrush to a long pole
and painted the ceiling of his bedroom
or Virginia wolf who wrote about mental
illness and physical illness and
realizing you know that we all have
experiences in our lives that thwart us
from what we think is our path or that
twist our mind out of the usual rut and
that there's an opportunity within that
if you're listening carefully enough and
if you're able to make space for it to
see what emerges and so I think for me
this experience of of dealing with
illness and living with these
limitations have forced me to do just
that because the
alternative would be to stay encased in
the trauma of those experience and
encased by maybe the bitterness or the
anger that might come with a sense that
whatever is be fallen you is unfair and
it's so much more interesting as Liz
Gilbert likes to say to be 1% more
curious about your circumstances than
afraid and so I've lived by that you
know I
have ample reason to be afraid ample
reason to live in a safe bubble and not
to put myself out there in the various
ways I've chosen to do but it's far more
interesting to get curious about them
and to figure out how to engage with
your limitations and whatever
constraints are placed upon you and to
see what you can do within that the
movie completes an arc with respect to
Jon's Story the ticking clock being the
performance of this Symphony the
American Symphony at Carnegie Hall but
your Arc doesn't land as cleanly we're
not quite
sure where you're at and what your
future might hold there's no punctuation
mark at the end of your story so like
how are you doing now like how is your
health like what is what is your current
prognosis and and how are you doing
well first of all I'm here uh so that
feels good I've gotten to watch this
film come out I just got to watch it
with all of my bone marrow transplant
nurses earlier this week uh which is
such a beautiful experience we'd
actually never seen each other without
masks on um so even that you know thank
God for waterproof mascara but I am in a
different kind of linal space now I'm in
a different kind of in between place I
will be in treatment indefinitely for
however long or short that might be and
when I got that news from my doctor he
said to me uh you have to live every day
as if it's your last which is the kind
of thing that you say to someone when
they're in that sort of limbo and you
know I
tried hard to figure out what that meant
for me but more specifically why it
instilled an intense sense of panic in
me and I
realized you know when you're trying to
live every day as if it's your last
you're thinking about how you can ring
as much out of life how you can like
seize the day and it like puts you in
this space of urgency and taking and
I've come to believe that as well
intentioned as that advice might be it's
terrible advice because if we were all
to live every day as if it were our last
we'd be robbing banks and I don't know
cheating on our spouses staring at trees
or eating ungodly amounts of ice cream
and so instead as I navigate this new
level of uncertainty which of course you
know
we all have none of us
know it's just more what theut is going
and acute for to look like and life is a
finite condition for all of us I've
shifted to a place of trying to live
every day as if it's my first which is
to say waking up with a sense of
curiosity and wonder that a newborn baby
might and rather than seeking out these
like huge important life moments seeking
out moments of play and tiny little
Joys and moments of nourishment and that
has made it such that I feel like I'm
moving through this uncertainty in a way
that doesn't put me in panic but places
me in a state of of Wonder and awe and
generosity
also I hope allows you to kind of really
enjoy this thing that's happening now
with the movie being out and everybody
enjoy I mean it that could be very
destabilizing for a lot of people you
know in Hollywood you're getting a lot
of attention there's a lot of press but
I would suspect having lived the life
that you've lived you can approach this
from a very different kind of healthier
place of like this is cool this is not
the most important thing and I can enjoy
it for what it is and not get caught up
in kind of the distracting irrelevancies
that you know kind of get packaged into
this type of experience it really has
it's changed everything for me um you
know and as grateful as I
am for you know the love that this
documentary is getting and as much as I
hope that it you know
resonates with the people who watch it
my priorities are
elsewhere instead of doing press I'm
piecing out tomorrow and going to the
beach with my friends for a couple of
days uh because that's what sounds fun
and nourishing to me and that's not
something I would have allowed
myself before you know David Brooks
talks about resume virtues uh in
contrast to eulogy
virtues and I'm living for the eulogy
virtues right now beautiful the movie is
called American Symphony and that's
because that's the name of the symphony
that JN is working on and we see that
creative process kind of unfold over the
course of the film and I was thinking
about the larger themes that play are
like the metaphor that's built into that
title I mean John is a master of
synthesizing a whole variety of
influences to
create his own type of music where you
can easily identify like oh this comes
from here and this comes from here and
when we were in Sicily he kind of talked
about that and performed his music and
you get to see how he plays with
everything from you know New Orleans
Jazz to Beethoven and and has this sort
of mashup approach to to create his art
and this
Symphony my sense is that the idea
behind it is although it's not kind kind
of overtly stated is that what would a
symphony look like like a classic
Symphony if it was about the
true American Experience like the
reality of the Melting Pot of influence
that crafted the soul of America in all
its pain and Beauty what would that look
like if it was a symphony I don't know
if that's accurate but that was how it
felt and then thinking about how he's
the result of so many influences and
then you being
Tunisian Swiss you know having these you
know like uh Muslim and Catholic
influences like this is an American
story like the American symphony is you
and John and your relationship as much
as it is this performance at Carnegie
Hall and the music that you know ended
up getting nominated for Grammys yeah
it's really about the Symphony of life
the way I understand it and the
synthesis of what can
feel like
contrasts we are so steeped in binary
thinking but the truth is most of us
aren't either happy or sad or healthy or
well you know the border between those
binaries is porous and much of us are
forced to live in synthesis to exist in
that messy middle and for John there's
that confusion he's in the show I'm a
pop star I'm a he gets like you know it
depends upon what genre you're
affiliated with you know that's how the
lens through which JN is celebrated or
criticized right like is he a classical
musician is he a jazz musician is he a
you know is he a pop star like who is he
and he's able to like play with that you
could tell it bothers him a little bit
that he gets a bunch of [__] about that
but isn't that America and isn't that
the tension that creates the beauty and
this is about him being in his own in
between or Lial gray area where he can't
be pigeon told or defined his version of
your experience trying to figure out
where you belong in the world where one
foot is on one side and one foot is on
the other well and I think in this world
where we're more divided than ever
before or My Hope Is that offering that
liminality as a third way and also you
know holding that
Duality um is
something that might be a balm to people
who feel like Misfits yeah who aren't
categorizable categorizable I think
that's a word yeah I don't know know
let's make it one John said about you
quote she's able to transform Darkness
alchemize Darkness and transmutate
darkness into
light what does that mean to
you you know I think we often think of
healing as ridding ourselves of the pain
that plagues us whatever that pain might
be and have tried to do that in every
number of ways from numbing it to
compartmentalizing it to dodging it to
stowing it as far down as I can but the
only way that I've been able to endure
these various things that have happened
is by engaging with that pain and
looking it directly in the eye
you know observing it the way you might
through the lens of a kaleidoscope where
you shift the prism and the light falls
in a different way and how are you
channeling that creative impulse now I
know you have a couple projects that
you're working on I'm working on a
couple different projects I'm working on
two books one called The Book of prompts
which is about the alchemical properties
of
journaling and and the other that I'm
calling drowning
practice about you know this year of
recurrence and really figuring out how
to surrender and float and it's 12 of
the paintings I made um paired with 12
essays and you
know
nothing about these
books feel intuitive to me books as you
know take a long time to write but again
I think you know the Temptation for me
is to stay glued to the present the
future feels like a scary place for me
right now but I guess these projects are
my way of of forcing myself to think
ahead and to make commitments to the
Future does that feel uncomfortable to
you to make future commitments
definitely it feels it feels like a very
you know tenuous
Act of planting a flag and and hoping to
God that that you'll get there but hope
is a courageous act more so for you than
the average person yeah
hope feels like a a dangerous and risky
act sometimes but what is the
alternative
exactly you have to you have to yeah
yeah
of all the things that you've done and
accomplished and suffered through
and high highs low lows you you
mentioned um we took a break that you
still feel like this impostor that you
do have an impostor
syndrome which is surprising to me as
somebody who said we're going to change
the world to JN as a young
person in some ways I love my impostor
syndrome it's the thing that fuels me
to work harder at my craft to push
myself but I also think it
comes
from a lifelong
experience
of feeling like a misfit on the outside
of things I've never quite fit and I've
come to embrace that and and to love
that even though it feels a little
uncomfortable in certain
situations and I'm you know someone who
feels a huge amount of fear I feel a
huge amount of fear before I do
anything and then I do it
anyway I do anything you mean embark on
a creative project or anything in
general because you've met fear in
places most people never
Venture so my instinct would be that
tackling a creative project is not scary
because you know real
fear yeah I think like a lot of
people you know who've been in the belly
of the Beast I feel most at
ease when the sticks are life or death I
know how to navigate that it's the
everyday part of life that is scarier to
me creative projects um I feel a huge
amount of fear as I was saying earlier I
have
to you know greet my fear welcome it and
then make space for the Curiosity that
leads me Beyond it yeah doesn't Liz talk
about that like a road trip like you can
come on the road trip fear but you have
to sit in the back seat or if you talk
too much you got to you're going in the
trunk or something exactly exactly yeah
what didn't end up in the in the movie
that you kind of wish had was there
anything that that was left out out that
you think would help complete the story
or I mean so much was left out given
well sure of course how much footage we
had you know and a thousand different
filmmakers would have made a thousand
different films but I like that at least
my role in the
story is left on this note of
ambiguity because there's an
ongoingness to that struggle there is no
knee ending as much as we might like one
that's wrapped up in a perfect bow of a
message um and so I appreciate that Matt
the
director you know left the viewer in
that gray space it feels like a much
more honest ending to that story than
the
Alternatives and what would you hope for
somebody to take away from the film John
says at one point in the film when he's
under a tremendous amount of pressure
and the stakes feel impossibly high he
asks a friend am I going to
crack and to me the question for all of
us isn't are we going to crack because I
think it's a certainty that we will have
moments of
cracking but my
hope that people will take from the film
is is what what you do when the crack
happens how you
continue showing up in love for the
people you care most about how you
improvise and pivot in the way that John
with his Jazz Roots uh so masterfully
does both in his music but also in his
personal life and how we can all
reimagine
survival as its own kind of creative
act
whether you think of yourself as
creative or not I think
creativity is a gift that we all have
access to and that we can all benefit
from yeah it's beautifully put there's a
moment in the film when John's
performing on stage at Carnegie Hall the
symphony is in full swing and the power
goes
out and there's a long pause
pause and then he begins to
play and what he plays is
improvised and that improvisation goes
on for 10 minutes 12
minutes and within that you see this
Montage like it's sort of a flashback of
your life together with John and that's
the whole movie what do you do when the
power goes
out you improvise you
improvise and his choice around that
improvisation
felt very personal to you it was like he
had an
awareness of the extended metaphor of
the power going
out and an opening in which he could
bring expression to all of his confusing
emotions around what was happening in
his personal life and what you were
enduring and it was like a little
missive to you in the middle of that
Symphony that says everything you need
to know
about who he is your
relationship
and survival as a creative act in my
opinion like it was so beautiful it was
really was quite
moving cuz there are so many reactions
you could
have if you're John in that moment and
the power goes out mid performance you
could stop the concert make an
announcement hope for the power to come
back on you could run off stage in
tears
but I love that he was able to
surrender
to the power going out to pause take
stock of what was happening even to
smirk a little bit in
defiance and
then to listen for whatever it was that
was arriving to him and to play and the
irony is nobody in the audience maybe
other than me knew that the power had
gone out oh really oh I didn't get that
from watching it I knew because I had
heard versions of it but no nobody had
any idea wow and that was the beauty of
it they just thought this is part of the
thing this is part of the thing there's
a 10-minute piano solo in the midst of
the symphony because why not yeah yeah
beautiful I want to close with some some
thoughts on on change which is something
that I think a lot about you're somebody
who's had to change in partnership with
changes that were foisted upon you
there's change that you have to weather
extern changes that you have no control
over and then there's change that you
initiate and as somebody who's been
compelled to change and then volunteered
for other changes how do you think
about the nature of being in
relationship with changes you don't have
control
over and then conversely how do
you how do you kind of Leverage your own
will
or s of purpose and direction in your
life to initiate positive changes in how
you're living your life what comes to
mind is a line uh from the Holocaust
Survivor and psychiatrist Victor Frankle
I think about it probably every day and
he says between stimulus and response
there is a space and within that
space is our freedom to choose how we
respond and within that response lies
our growth and our
freedom and so I like many other
people have you know been faced with
something that's happened that has maybe
on its surface left me feeling powerless
but I always hold in mind the fact that
I have the power to choose my response
to the
stimulus and that that's a great deal of
power and that there's a great deal of
agency within that and so no
matter how powerless I feel I always try
to locate whatever that small Act of
agency is that I have and so for me
that's looked like writing and painting
and learning how to drive and who knows
what else will come down the road but I
take a great degree of comfort and
knowing
that within how we
choose to respond lies the power to
transform whatever it is that you're
experiencing whatever it is that makes
you
feel disempowered or even helpless it's
easy for me to say that I don't think
it's easy for you to say that I think
you've earned the right to say that but
I also want to say that
you know whatever that response is it
usually takes a long time for me to
figure out what that is this isn't
something that happens overnight you're
a human being yeah
exactly it takes many months of binge
watching Grace anatomy and raging
against the world sometimes to get to
the place where you figure out how you
want to respond to something and that's
okay too yeah thank you this is really
beautiful spend this time with you I was
very deeply moved by the film I think
it's just a
beautiful poetic work of art it's only
been out for like two days at this point
um but already the reception is is
pretty dramatic uh it's nothing but
universally adored at this point and I'm
excited for you know kind of the fun
adventure that you get to have with this
and like I said earlier I hope that you
can just be present and enjoy it for
what it is it's a pretty special Peak
experience that I think you've more than
earned for yourself and nobody is more
deserving than you and John I just I
love you guys individually and as a
couple it's inspiring to see you
collaborate and co-create together and I
wish only the best for both of you
thankk you yeah we love you and we're
grateful to you for being our wonderful
dinner companion at that terrifying
event and hopefully our future dinner
companion at Le terrifying events yeah
cool um all right well great well
hopefully we can do this again very
appreciate it thanks than you
peace that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change in
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. roll.com if
you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing you can
do is to subscribe to the show on Apple
podcasts on Spotify and on YouTube and
leave a review and or comment supporting
the sponsor who support the show is also
important and appreciated and sharing
the show or your favorite episode with
friends or on social media is of course
awesome and very helpful and finally for
podcast updates special offers on books
the meal planner and other subjects
please subscribe to our newsletter which
you can find on the footer of any page
at Rich roll.com Today's show was
produced and engineered by Jason Cameo
with additional audio engineering by
Kale Curtis the video edition of the
podcast was created by Blake Curtis with
assistance by our creative director Dan
Drake portraits by Dave Greenberg
graphic and social media assets courtesy
of Daniel CIS thank you Georgia Wy for
copywriting and website management and
of course our theme music was created by
Tyler Patt Trapper Patt and Harry mathys
appreciate the love love the support see
you back here soon peace plant namaste
[Music]
yay